que lexie poulin et dottore liste rt
france soir alexis café vous retenir de
qu'avez vous retenu de ce grand oral sur
le logement des candidats à la
présidentielle aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai que le logement c'est
enfin un thème dont on parle jusqu'à
présent ils étaient oubliés de la
campagne et pourtant c'est le poste de
dépenses le plus important les chiffres
qui font froid dans le dos 300000 sdf
qui est des chiffres qui ont plus que
doublé en deux ans les 4 millions de mal
logés de la fondation abbé pierre et on
a eu à la suite tous les candidats
majoritairement de gauche qui sont venus
expliciter leur mesure
alors tous sont à revoir les minima
sociaux à taxer les plus riches avec lui
et c'est peut-être le retour de lier
cette avoir un grand plan de bâti
construire de nouveaux logements et donc
il y avait une candidate en revanche qui
a été extrêmement floue plutôt mal
préparés certains ont même parlé de
naufrage s'était christiane taubira qui
avait bien du mal à répondre de mesures
qu'elle avait expliqué sur un coin de
table sans chiffre finalement sans
vraiment savoir et puis ce plan zéro sdf
en cinq ans de jean luc mélenchon qui
rappelle les promesses un bien sûr
qu'ils avaient qu'ils sont fait à chaque
fois en début de quinquennat c'était le
cas pour nicolas sarkozy pourrait mener
le maquereau là ils essayent de
s'appuyer justement sur le rapport de la
fondation abbé pierre mais on voit que
malgré les nombreuses mesures il y a
beaucoup de travail à faire compte tenu
de du bilan calamiteux des bleus le
maquereau en matière de logement social
justement bilan calamiteux c'est à dire
parce que vous l'avez dit il y avait eu
quand même pas mal de promesses et il y
avoir aussi nous rappeler un oui alors
dans le rapport de la fondation abbé
pierre il est écrit que c'est un parent
pauvre du quinquennat il ya eu des
coupes budgétaires inédites voire des
attaques contre l' or le logement social
et rien n'a été fait pour encadrer la
hausse des loyers et l'explosion du prix
du logement emmanuel macron a fait du
emmanuel macron c'est à dire une
politique qui a accentué les inégalités
qui a profité aux plus riches mais qui
n'a pas permis d'aller chercher des
solutions pour le logement c'est 15
milliards par exemple d'euros qui ont
été ôtés aux plus modestes avec la
suppression de l'apl entre autres et
puis entre 2018 et 2022 l'état a pris
aux organismes hlm environ 6 milliards
d'euros pour faire des économies ces
deux cent mille logements qui n'ont pas
pu être construits finalement depuis
1984 il n'y avait jamais eu une
politique aussi peu orienté vers le
logement que celle des balais de macron
donc là encore quand on parle du bilan
d' emmanuel macron bien il faut voir
combien ce bilan est calamiteux dans
nombreux domaines et dans le logement
particulièrement on voit à l'oeuvre
cette politique d du creusement des
inégalités qu'il a mis en place depuis
son élection et puis alexis on en parle
est un pendant que la gauche par les
logements la droite elle faisait son
grand oral devant le syndicat alliance
oui alors c'était deux salles deux
ambiances sein d'un côté vous aviez les
candidats plutôt de de gauche qui
parlait logement et de l'autre côté les
candidats de droite qui parlait sécurité
et police avec les syndicats policiers
de grands oraux très différents on a
l'impression qu'on avait affaire à des
camps politiques qui se raccrocher à
leurs totems d'un côté le social et de
l'autre la sécurité reste à voir ce
qu'il en ressortira je trouve ça dommage
ça aurait été bien d'avoir les candidats
de toutes les couleurs politiques pour
parler de ces deux sujets même s'il y
avait des représentants un des candidats
de chaque côté et c'est vrai que la
sécurité c'est un thème important y
compris pour les candidats de gauche qui
ont souvent du mal à se positionner par
rapport à ça ou a même expliqué qu'elle
pourrait être leur politique et pour le
logement bien c'est ce qu'on a vu avec
le bilan des mails macron il y avait là
un problème mais on va voir de toute
façon c'est zorro cc se multiplier sur
des thèmes différents en fonction de
l'agenda bien sûr de la campagne
présidentielle et puis on attend enfin
qu emmanuel macron soit candidat et
peut-être prendra-t-il part aux débats
même si le porte-parole gabriela talent
adx n'avait aucun intérêt ce serait
quand même bien de voir le président
défendre son bilan avant de se
représenter devant les français puisque
un dernier sondage vient de sortir et
ses 57 % des français qui pensent que
l'élection des modèles macron en 2017 a
été une mauvaise chose pour le pays donc
il va falloir s'expliquer merci beaucoup
alexis paulin et organiste rt france